petite lou sympathie et condoléances
pour les familles des victimes dans ces
de ces attentats terrible je vais te
vanter d'avoir notre ministre comme
d'habitude avec ses formules creuses des
lieux communs des choses qu'on utilise
près de police
le canada se doit en tant que membre de
la communauté internationale de faire
tout ce qu'on veut à l'échelle
internationale pas pour contrer cette
montée du terrorisme et de famille ou
proches donc avec nous ensemble unis
grignard et justin trudeau ont réagi
chacun à leur façon à l'annoncé de la
mort de six québécois dans l' attaque
terroriste au burkina faso justin
trudeau on vient l'entendre a essuyé de
vives critiques de la part des familles
qui ont été touchées par ce drame
daniel tâche à michel bonsoir 3 contente
de vous retrouver alors certains ont
accusé le premier ministre trudeau
d'avoir manqué disons d'empathie dans
cette affaire michel est ce que justin
trudeau a été à la hauteur des
événements selon vous non franchement
non et ça s'était produit à peu près de
la même façon souvenez-vous alors des
attentats de paris monsieur trudeau
avait pas trouvé le temps ni les mots et
ça a été la même chose écouter car le
conjoint d'une victime la ferme la ligne
on est du premier ministre parce qu'il
trouve que ces propos sont insignifiants
ça veut dire qu'ils ses poches alors non
je pense que monsieur trudeau a pas
trouvé le temps on peut trouver
l'endroit non plus aller aller faire ses
commentaires dans une mosquée à
peterborough parlé d' islamophobie sitap
approprié et moi ça me donne
l'impression au delà du
en fait de l'incapacité des ondes
monsieur trudeau a exprimé son empathie
ça donne l'impression qu'il ya personnes
autour de lui il ya il n'y a pas de
québécois de francophones pour lui dire
écoute là c'est un drame de ce qui se
passe au québec là on va laisser faire
la mosquée qu'on va s'en aller à québec
et je pense que ça va être un problème
permanent six personnes lui donnent le
feeling de ce qui se passe au québec par
rapport à ça monsieur couillard lui
était à québec bon avec des masses et
c'est dans l'ordre des choses mais mais
a trouvé vraiment le bon ton les bons
mots comme d'ailleurs il l'avait fait
lors des attentats de paris
il a su mieux comprendre l'émotion
laksaci beaucoup mieux et traduire la
sienne oui d'achat évidemment ces
attentats n'ont pas eu tout à fait le
même écho dans le reste du pays mais est
ce que la réaction de justin trudeau
d'après vous était appropriée il y en a
qui l'ont critiqué donc moi et pour des
raisons que michel a dit mais aussi le
fait que dans ce que si monsieur trudeau
s'il allait rester à la mosquée il avait
une occasion parfaite de faire appel à
la communauté musulmane dans cette
situation et dire écoutez on est tous
contre le terrorisme ensemble vous avez
votre parti à jouer pour contrer
l'islamisme poldi là mais les radicaux
les fondamentalistes il aurait pu
utiliser cette occasion essentiellement
pour rassembler tous les canadiens y
compris la communauté musulmane contre
ce fléau mais il l'a pas fait et la peau
dit qu'on va non plus poursuivre en
justice ceux qui ont pris la vie à ces
six québécois à ouagadougou et ensuite
aussi à jakarta alors vraiment il a
manqué surtout pour plein de points et
de plus à prendre trois jours je pense
pour appeler la famille après qu'il est
à davos au système ans qu'il aurait dû
faire ça à voir qu'il était parti daniel
la famille
des victimes a aussi critiqué justin
trudeau pour la position du canada dans
la lutte contre le terrorisme dans la
lutte contre l'état islamique on a
entendu madame carrie là dessus mais
c'est clair le gouvernement n'a pas
l'intention de changer de câbles à y
maintient une maintient sa politique
écoutez officiellement oui sauf que il
ya un flou dans cette politique et je
suis poli dans cette politique des
affaires étrangères du gouvernement tous
nos sens que on sait pas trop où on s'en
va on sait que des hésitations les
décisions original c'était de retirer
les chasseurs de 2,2 de l'irak et de
l'aciérie ils sont encore là ils seront
probablement jusqu'à la date
d'expiration prévue c'est-à-dire fin
mars
il ya un film cette politique là on
recense justin trudeau un malaise quand
y question d'affaires international
c'était vrai vers la fin du régime
harper quand le gouvernement
conservateur pour des décisions
importantes sur la sécurité
ça a été vrai pendant la campagne
électorale se l'est depuis qu'il est
premier ministre on comptait beaucoup
sur ces familles aux deux ministres
expérience qui a une bonne connaissance
de deux des affaires étrangères pour
donner direction aux fermes précise
claire à cette politique étrangère on
l'attend toujours
parce que lui aussi tarde un peu à
réagir de tarder un peu à réagir
là-dessus
est-ce que tu achats ce qui complique
pas les choses c'est aussi le fait qu'on
sache pas vraiment ce qui va se passer
ensuite parce que si le gouvernement dit
le canada va agir plus du côté
humanitaire va peut-être faire de la
formation de en irak mais on ne sait pas
vraiment encore ce qui va ce qu'on va
faire mais on est de plus c'est un peu
ironique monsieur trudeau va enlever nos
avions de chasse mais en même temps ça
veut dire qu'on va augmenter notre
capacité sur le terrain ce qui mettrait
potentiellement en péril des soldats
canadiens qui se trouveraient dans la
ligne de tir on a vu ça des gens malgré
le fait qu'ils sont pas supposées dans
de s'engager avec l'ennemi ça arrive
parfois c'est arrivé parce qu'ils sont
en position de d'entraîneur dans des
situations qui peuvent devenir des
situations de guerre d'une minute à une
autre alors c'est dans un sens
contradictoire que monsieur trudeau nous
retire de l'action sur un front mais mr
peut-être les canadiens sur un autre
michel est ce que certains ont aussi dit
qu'il court le gouvernement semblait
avoir un peu de mal à s'ajuster à la
réalité parce que bien sûr cette prise
de position ça a été fait avant les
attentats de paris avant les attentats
de ouagadougou s capaves que certains se
demandent si ya pas lieu justement
d'ajuster la politique a écouté pendant
la campagne électorale monsieur trudeau
a beaucoup joué sur la nostalgie de du
pacifisme et du bonne entente isme
canadien doleires de lester b pearson et
de son père aussi c'était relativement
facile le bon de jouer les gérants
d'estrade à ce moment là c'est bon c'est
de bonne guerre quand on est dans
l'opposition
mais là il est au pouvoir et la réalité
est que le canada et le monde
d'aujourd'hui ils ne sont pas des même
que celui de l'époque de personnes et et
de trudeau père et ça il doit prendre
acte
là c'est la deuxième occasion qu'il a il
y avait eu les attentats de paris l'oeil
à ouagadougou et jakarta il ya deux
occasions de rajuster le tir de dire
écoutez
il va falloir en finir avec l'état
islamique c'est vrai j'avais dit que
mais bon je me rends compte qu'il n'y a
pas d'autre solution que d'intervenir
militairement et
les canadiens comprendrait parfaitement
et applaudir et je pense même s'il faut
rappeler quand même que ces attentats
ils ont pas été revendiquée par l'état
islamique mais par un autre groupe
djihadiste oui tout à fait mais tout le
monde qu'on comprend que la première
menace terroriste actuellement vient de
l'état islamique et je pense que
monsieur trudeau devra prendre acte je
vais juste parler un petit mot de davos
parce que là aussi on semble avoir
peut-être un décalage entre ce que dit
monsieur trudeau là-bas que tout va bien
que les gens doivent venir investir et
sol pendant ce temps là on sent bien qu
ici au pays la situation est pas un rose
rose la tâche en voyait pas du tout et
même le maire nenshi a critiqué le maire
de calgary
mais ce trudeau quand il a dit qu'il
faut n'est pas conservateur quand même
monsieur radio est d'habitude vous
pourrez un allié de monsieur trudeau
mais quelqu'un qui était qui est plus
favorable à lui politiquement et il a
critiqué le fait que monsieur trudeau a
dit qu'il faut miser non sur les
ressources mais sûr qu'on en dit en
anglais witherspoon est c'est à dire le
savoir des canadiens le savoir faire
c'est sûr que oui l'économie du savoir
c'est important l'économie interne est
important mais les ressources aussi
c'est important il faut pas on peut pas
négliger ça c'est un domaine cycle et
qu'on sait qu'un jour ça va ça va
revenir
malgré les aspirations de leonardo
dicaprio mais on a toujours besoin d'une
épaule alors dont le daniel est ce que
est ce que au lieu on n'en demande pas
trop au gouvernement de prendre ces
décisions là parce qu'ils viennent
d'arriver au pouvoir commencer juste
trois mois est ce qu'on doit faire
ça fait trois mois mais depuis trois
mois le dollar canadien a perdu 17 prix
du baril de pétrole est passé de 46
avaient peur de la bourse de toronto a
perdu presque 2000 points et fonds
monétaire international- viennent
d'évaluer la croissance du canada pour
les prochaines années a évidemment ce
n'est pas la faute de justin trudeau
pour lui dire c'est votre fossiles
dollar a perdu autant de valeurs et ses
erreurs ses terres sauf que à partir de
maintenant la balle est dans ses mains
c'est à lui de jouer c'est à lui de
montrer aux canadiens qu'il est capable
de relancer cette économie qui est très
très très mal en point et il va falloir
beaucoup plus que il a fait un joli
discours hier à davos je vous le concède
c'était plein de belles formules très
bien écrit c'est un peu racoleur sauf
qu'il n'a rien dit de très nouveau
tu as chalon mentionné on passe de
l'économie basée sur les ressources
naturelles a eu notre économie mais
laquelle donc un gros défi à tout le
monde est prêt à donner sa chance au
coureur jusqu'au budget c'est à ce
moment là aux portes en juin sur la
direction économique monsieur trudeau
veut donner au canada très bien alors
passons maintenant au pq dans le caucus
s'est terminée aujourd'hui à saguenay ce
qui semble surtout avoir retenu
l'attention
c'est toute la controverse suscitée par
l'institut de la soude son lot de
recherche sur la souveraineté
son financement est la réaction de
pierre karl péladeau michel
expliquez-nous un peu l'enjeu parce
qu'il ya dix et il ya les organismes ce
type qui existent du côté fédéral pour
l'ipo pour le fédéralisme est ce qu'un
problème ou pas que pierre karl péladeau
disent qu'il va financer lui même cet
institut il ya un problème si cet
institut la et une api indice du parti
québécois à partir du moment où c'est le
chef qui annonce qui va créer un
institut
il semble qu'ils soient celui qui
désigne aussi les membres du conseil
d'administration et là ils veulent
financer alors c'est difficile quand on
présente la chose de cette façon là de
dire que c'est un institut indépendant
du parti québécois et c'est là que le
bât blesse si c'est un est une émanation
du pq il sera soumis aux règles
de financement des partis politiques
c'est à dire des contributions maximum
de 100 dollars par individu y compris
monsieur péladeau
si c'est un institut indépendant en tout
cas la théorie là ça peut avoir le
statut d'oeuvre de bienfaisance comme
l'idée fédérale le think tank
fédéraliste dont tout le monde parle
tout le monde peut y contribuer sans
limite et ça donne même droit à des
déductions d'impôts mais pour ça il faut
que ça ait l'air où ça au moins les
apparences d'un institut indépendant ce
monsieur péladeau avait confié la tâche
moutons
l'organisme la fin de l'organisation des
des désirs des organismes unis le oui
enfin les successeurs du conseil de la
souveraineté
il ya probablement le popoli maladie oui
je pense que manqué de finesse et là ils
s'enfarge à charest et devrait savoir
mieux écouter monsieur péladeau a donné
plein d'argent qu'ils n'étaient pas
politiques de mariage le sais pas ce que
j'ai vu ces chèques la quantité l'appui
connais les règles du jeu se veut être
indépendant comme organisme ne peut pas
écrire un parti politique le but d'un
organisme de recherche comme ça c'est
qu'ils sont apolitiques
ils reçoivent des contributions dans le
cas du feu yeux par exemple des du monde
des affaires
dans le cas de l'institut broadbent des
syndicats mais pas de parti politique
parce qu'autrement tu n'as aucune
indépendance et alors il ne connaît très
bien cela s'il veut faire ça qui le
consacre un organisme indépendant mais
des universités l'uqam chaque pourrait
chapeauter soit n'importe-quoi n'est pas
le parti ni lui personnellement daniel
mais aussi la réaction de pierre karl
péladeau dans tout ça oui c'est spécial
mais nous pensions tous les ménages se
poursuit
attention 3 chaussures est ce que est ce
que pierre karl péladeau peut financer
l'institut et moi aussi combien d'autres
ça m'agace qu'il songe à le faire mais
attendons de voir ce que dira le
directeur général des élections la
suspense peau qui se fera encore
prononcé deuxièmement est-ce que ce
devrait être reconnu comme une oeuvre de
bienfaisance
non pas plus que l'idée fédérale je
convaincu que les gouvernements ya des
oeuvres de bienfaisance y ont bien plus
besoin de crédits d'impôt et d'argent
que ces deux organismes qui sont tout à
fait légitimes
on ne te voit qu'on voir sa cause
mettant sur le cadre qui n'a rien à voir
avec les oeuvres de bienfaisance et
troisièmement pour ce qui est de la
réaction de monsieur péladeau a accès on
s'attend de chef de l'opposition à ce
qu'ils aient une certaine cherche le bon
mot mais qui s'élève au dessus de la
mêlée parce que si à chaque fois que le
péquin peut il réagit comme il l'a fait
depuis deux ou trois jours
il va trouver le temps long mais oui je
pense que le manque de données
chercheur il faudrait qu'elle le flegme
nécessaire pour les positions et écoutez
moi j'ai l'impression que en particulier
de la part de monsieur fourni on cherche
simplement à faire grimper monsieur
péladeau dans les rideaux ils tombent
dans le panneau à chaque fois et ça ça
devient un problème je convaincu que
dans son entourage dont sa on s'arrache
les cheveux de voir la façon avec
laquelle il aurait agi il va falloir
qu'ils apprennent à contrôler il a
vraiment ça dérape complètement mais là
on est dans un débat politique alors on
argumente pas avec des menaces de
poursuites et des mises en demeure dans
un débat politique et technique aussi ce
qui fait qu'en et sur son facebook
s'attaque à ma famille de ma nuit veux
pas qu'on s'attaque à lui mis en mai
dans demeure la cac qui menace de mettre
en demeure qui que ce soit et là ils
attaquent les autres parce que ils
devraient une poursuite mais la survie a
taclé y attaquent la presse et ses
chroniqueurs qui disent à ces encierros
courus essentiellement secondes
essentiellement ce qu'on a dit tous les
trois ce soir samedi sur 6 mais son
parti québécois en ce moment je écouter
il me semble y avoir un malaise
il me semble que monsieur péladeau est
encore en train d'apprendre comment
faire de la politique c'est un look
apprentissage est pas évident
certains hommes d'affaires paul martin
pour ne pas le nommer n'a jamais réussi
à la prendre
ah c'est pas facile à méfier des
poursuites mois pour avoir vu trente ans
de débat politique s'est tous les
députés qui se sont assez ce genre
d'étude avait été poursuivi il sera
encore les prisons seraient pleines à
écouter merci beaucoup d'avoir été là ce
soir on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
au sujet de discussion à cette rentrée
merci au revoir et dimanche à 11 heures
aux coulisses du pouvoir emmanuelle
latraverse entretien avec la ministre de
la justice
québec stéphanie vallée